their visions varied in scope and size
but in each instance they demonstrated
the magic and power of movies the
nominees for best achievement in
directing are for Billy Elliot Steven
Daldry
for Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon and
Lee for Erin Brockovich Steven
Soderbergh for gladiator Ridley Scott
for traffic Steven Soderbergh
and he asked her goes to Steven
Soderbergh for traffic
and third nomination for Steven
Soderbergh he has also nominated this
evening for Erin Brockovich
Oh
suddenly going to work tomorrow doesn't
seem like such a good idea
my daughter Sarah's asleep in London
she's missing this unfortunately there
are a lot of people to thank
rather than thank some of them publicly
I think going to thank all of them
privately what I want to say is I want
to thank anyone who spends part of their
day creating I don't care if it's a book
a film a painting a dance a piece of
theatre a piece of music anybody anybody
who spends part of their day sharing
their experience with us
I think this world would be unlivable
without art and I thank you that
includes the academy that includes my
fellow nominees here tonight thank you
for inspiring me thank you for this